m
[Musique]
la vie si tu qu'on est astucieux bell
bell est la plus grande fête le plus
sérieux n'avait pas joué depuis il fait
mine de vouloir punir un ami
[Musique]
jean fabrice comment vas-tu bel oiseau
je ne vais pas mal
ah et puis je suis très fier de mon
petit ou non c'est vrai ça a été tout il
est mignon elle vient classe a ont la
première fois bonjour tout ouïe ouïe où
il a il a appris la vie dans d'autres
ruches au pot c'est bien ça commence à
être très fort bon et toi tu es fort sur
les expériences et bien écoute je crois
que j'ai préparé quelque chose qui peut
être intéressant nous allons essayer de
figurer une sorte de bataille navale
un petit peu d'imagination et bien
entendu wind river alors le champ de
bataille en quelque sorte
sera ce couvercle de boîte de conserve
que vous voyez et puis toujours avec
beaucoup d'imagination
les bateaux seront les morceaux de créer
que j'ai disposé sur cette boîte sur ce
couvercle bon alors je vais mettre à
l'intérieur de ce couvercle du vinaigre
regardez bien ces d'yvinec tout
simplement attention ça va pas sauter
sur le petit et attention parce qu'au
début ça va bouillir un peu hein
alors il faudrait d'abord que ce soit
bien horizontale je vois comment ça va
se passer ça faire la forme est partout
tu vois c'est des fournées instant ça ne
fait rien mais oui attends tu vois là
alors maintenant oui c'est pas il paraît
que ça devrait bouger et ans j'en ai
promis à ses marais season tard il faut
il fallait season suffisamment la rizza
season seulement le problème c'est que
ça n'est pas très horizontale voilà pas
du tout d'ailleurs la voiture c'est ça
qui est très compliqué ça marche et ça
ça y est ils bougent regard gaffe
tous les bateaux bouge regardent ils se
déplacent comme des escargots regardes
tu vois
pour la table et c'est bouger là on
faisait place il laisse des traces
tu les vois là les inscrits alors ça je
vais te dire un fabre un regard je ne
fais pas souvent de compliments mais
cette expérience c'est inouï regardez
vous j'en ai un qui avance la regarde
vraiment top
il retourne sur lui-même ne mange pas
titoune est inédit c'est étonnant cette
affaire là alors tu vois on dirait des
bateaux qui laisse dans la merde et
rennais et on croire une véritable
bataille rangée voix qui bouge
il ya des cuirassés qui se rapproche des
porte-avions et un croiseur là qui va
foncer à l'attaqué où il y en a deux qui
vont se rentrer dedans regarde hausse
est inouï sa part saïd touche tu vois
europe 32 dans la sas et c'est
incroyable c'est formidable alors ça ça
peut durer comme ça pendant des heures
voilà ce serait le gers à titu oui j'en
demande en fait c'est épatant nous
allons jouer aux motos mot le mot
thamond avec bien entendu les cartons
représentant des personnages des objets
des animaux etc
et à chaque fois une syllabe et à partir
de ses syllabes
nous formons d'autres mots na qui sont
très forts à ce jeu là vous avez gagné
oui mais aujourd'hui je suis non ce
n'est pas à moi je crois que ça va bien
marcher
je prends cinq cartons comme toujours
et alors nous alors nous avons une fée
oui nous avons un nez nous avons qu'est
ce que c'est que c'est un bol c'est un
bol c'est un bol
nous avons un des voilà le dit un des et
ça c'est d'un jonas un jeu ça je un jour
je cartel c'est un jeu car oui c'est
vrai bon voilà le fait mener c'est une
bonne idée folle des jeux ça ne veut
rien dire
bénévole des jeunes on sait pas
d'émotion donc bien faire avec ça je
crois qu'il faut que tu continues est
resté groggy
non non attendez attendez été arrêtés ce
qui la pousse le sud je crois je crois
que j'ai un mot vas-y d2d ni des le jeu
le jeu car oui des lieux mais je n'ai
déjà pas bon formidable et parce que je
suis assez content de moi là mais il est
jeune et j'ai trouvé ça aussi c'est très
très brillant à raser je n'ai pas dit ça
s'écrit bien entendu comme cela un
déjeuner c'est bien tu sais bien que
c'est bien assez de c est moi qui vais
trouver assez jamais mais alors là on ne
peut rien faire il faut sortir encore on
écarte aussi aller à la pêche oui ça
c'est un cetain c'est un coin c'est un
rose alors oui on s'est érodée vous
savez l'ancienne appellation de rôti 1re
au parisien qu'est ce que c'est ça ça
c'est une unis est une amie oui oui ben
alors là moi je suis vraiment trouve
être cousues ni très difficile stop je
devais je pouvais d'effroi garder bol
oui et au les boléros les robots les
rouge et noir cette date
boléro c'est aussi un petit vêtement
mais oui alors boléro au ccri comme cela
très simplement bo est le héros un
boléro et voilà ça donne des envies
c'est vrai à oui on a été fort à tous
ceux qui ont la leur jardi moi c'est toi
qui va tirer la carte postale non
j'avais quand même te laisser le faire
va pense que c'est toi qui a trouvé le
premier monde alors tu me désigne c'est
celle-là la selle
oui je suis d'accord avec un très très
très beaux dessins très beaux dessins
wii qui te ressemble un peu d'ailleurs
tous vous suit cette lettre vient de
laura augias habitants chemin de baroin
ne s'est pas exactement où cela ça doit
être sur la sur l' enveloppe le reste de
la de l'adresse en tous les cas chère
petite laura puisque tu nous a fait le
plaisir de nous envoyer lettre et de
dessiner une espèce de pouce moussu ça
lui ressemble enfin de profiter
phénomène c'est pas mal on lui enverra
un disque avec la chanson dès qu'il aura
tu l'auras avait pas d'urgence à 7 ans
je revois fier de lui tous reçus oui
c'est à nous à nous c'est à dire 2 on y
va tout à leur belle bella tout à
l'heure à mon cher fabrice je crois que
cette fois ci je vais te coller ah ah
oui parce que j'ai un mot ou très long
au onze lettres hall alors oui en gros
je ne pense pas c'est trop long ça
commence par quoi ça commence par un m1
comme maurice
oui alors un est le 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
ouais et la dernière 1 1 voilà alors
toujours dans les moyens de transport
oui oui mais laissent ils sont venus
avec que ça rien grand sport assez
particulier quand même sur le sur l'eau
oh non ça va pas sur l'eau dans les
heures dans les airs exactement dans les
airs mais attention c'est un un moyen de
transport assez particulier parce que
plutôt un moyen de de promenade tout va
on dans les arènes oui on se promène
dans les airs oui ça un moteur non non
non non non ça marche tout à fait
autrement mais si je te le dis tu vas
trouver tout de suite alors ça marche
il ya des clubs d'ailleurs aux environs
de paris ma faute je donne une lettre
oui un là la troisième par exemple oui
c'est un n
oui bah oui ça correspond bien ce à quoi
je pense mais attentif à m combien de
lettres matuidi a jeté 10 en 11 lettres
ça va pas mon pauvre stosur il ya de
l'air à l'intérieur et de l'air chaud
oui oui tu penses à une montgolfière de
montgolfières bravo bras mais comme en
écriture montgolfière la montgolfière
comme ça se prononce pas rm ong ou jiwa
lé top c'est déjà faux bon chat bon rat
bon tu vas tu parles harriet c'est
montpellier-3 là une fois fiers et moins
de thé et bien parce que ça ne vient pas
de mons ce qui est à moi ça vient
on de ses inventeurs les frères
montgolfier j'ai pas mon rôle
non c'est pas mon goal sierre d'ailleurs
madame est évidemment oui enfin ça m'a
écouté est-ce que tu c'est la première
fois qu'on a expérimenté le premier vol
en montgolfière est ce que tu sais ce
qu'il y avait ce qu'on avait mis dans la
nacelle bah je crois qu'il y avait des
animés annie morris à mes amis oui
comment y avait un mouton un coq et un
canard ah oui soit on va aller dire saad
el baile avait très contente
bonne idée on y va on est l'anti
[Musique]
kabylisme jouer avec moi c'est pas si la
musique du bêta oui tu veux que j'ai
fait des progrès et à la guitare j'ai
remarqué bon alors je vais jouer à te
faire découvrir le début de la musique
d'une chanson grâce à des mots inachevé
que tu complètera par des notes sellette
attention je te préviens que si tu es un
peu endormi c'est une chanson qui va te
payer tu vas me clément réveiller
réveillé avec le riz tout en bas oui et
tu veux si tu te trouve en vacances à la
campagne si tu penses que tu vas pouvoir
dormir tranquillement loin du bruit et
bien non car il ya beaucoup de bruit
dans la campagne
dix petits cris qui chantent par exemple
est galles les les fringants mettreen
d'être des musiciens dit c'est vrai ah
bon alors laisse les cigales et les
cigales t'empêche de fierté petit fils
à londres souton pas vraiment son
parapluie a attiré pidio sipa à chute à
l'eau par un saint mais oui en être des
notes de musique tu fais marcher didot
et dans la chanson à puisqu'ici pc et
puis quand bull qui a pu avec son nez
même et puis quand bull si tu ne me
laisses pas finir de manger des pc web
ont donné à la pluie est vraiment
impossible à leur rapide s'il faudrait
savoir qu'est-ce qui joue ici
si c'est moi alors alors alors puisque
je suis dans le coeur de ma chanson je
continue et dans cette chanson c'est un
d'un autre animal qu'il s'agit plus un
noise ou de new richmond qui n'a pas une
très bonne une mutation réputation
réputation mais table deux mois le rapt
est bavard impénitent dans son histoire
il est caché dans un bois riez et niall
sa présence signale sa présence il
signale sa présence en le chante à tue
tête
il chante pour te rappeler que ce n'est
plus le moment de dormir c'est le moment
de travailler il faut faire comme la
veille qui est levé depuis longtemps le
soleil oui parfait maintenant l'oeil ça
y est j'ai pu me lever oui bon c'est
parfait tu vas pouvoir jouer les débuts
de la brousse et puis quand bull veut
bien mais c'est jouer parce qu'il est
oui mais siens il est à gaza là il quand
on réussit avec le hic c'est qu'à vous
reste pas le nôtre
écoutez bien meilleure l'afrique à ce
jeu là d'une rétine à l'air
non plus
dans la pie qui chante pour ya une fille
dans le premier jean paul a pu chanter
bravo à monique palhol seulement vous
tout ça vous ne mettez pas vous êtes là
il vous démange et fabrice je trouve
dans notre intimité tous les deux on
pensait pas tranquille se passe mais
c'est vrai ça ailleurs j'arrive pour la
chanson sourit fabrice bien c'est rapide
[Musique]
et ne ferait que la vie majed s'est
désisté et g shock que des choses pour
les tomes je n'y pas de baignoire mais
il faudra faire attention les cas de
femmes y sont pas des sorties
médiatiques ça me sens heureux car il
aime la vie
eh oui
il
sans fil
j'arrive à jouer aujourd'hui vouloir
devenir familier
e
[Musique]